one update from from ukraine
that is pretty astonishing it's from
elon musk elon musk is apparently
single-handedly providing internet to
parts of ukraine right now elon musk has
this starling system he's got lots of
satellites up in the sky the satellites
are able to provide internet almost
anywhere and so he's got starlink set up
to provide internet to ukraine so after
the russians went out and hit some
ukrainian telecoms uh starlink is just
providing that and uh musk sent out a
tactical warning he said important
warning starlink is the only non-russian
communication system still working in
some parts of ukraine so probability of
being targeted is high please use it
with caution turn on starlink only when
needed and place the antenna away as far
away from people as possible place like
camouflage over the antenna to avoid
visual detection
because that it it's not everything just
turns on with the flip of a switch in
the smart in the smart world
tactics matter placement matters
geography matters that's what's playing
out and it's it's shocking the world
we are we are seeing the collapse of the
post-cold war order of relative peace
and stability at least in
the civilized world at least in the
western world it's all set it's all good
no more big wars we're just gonna have
wars of empire well
not so much
and
if if the bidens of the world are in
charge if the liberal establishment that
led us to this point is in charge we are
headed
in a very different direction and we're
we are headed for much more conflict
much more strife a place in which
traditional
nationhood
and tactics and militaries are going to
matter right now go to ziprecruiter.com
knowles i think it's great to learn new
skills i'm always trying to keep my mind
active become more useful i'd love to
learn how to save more money
i'd love to learn how to own a plant
without killing it i haven't perfected
that yet but i will try
i love learning new things just like the
zip recruiter their ai is always
learning so if you're hiring their ai
gets better and faster at finding the
right candidates for all of your roles
right now you can try it for free at
zippercooter.com
knowles zip recruiter uses this powerful
matching technology to find and match
the right candidates with your job it's
not just spaghetti at the wall it
proactively presents these candidates to
you then you find your favorites
ziprecruiter will go invite them to
apply makes the whole process much
faster smoother saves you time saves you
money most important investment is your
personnel right now you can try zip
recruiter for free at ziprecruiter.com
knowles that is ziprecruiter.com
k-n-o-w-l-e-s
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
i'm so glad you like that clip now if
you want the whole show you've got to
ring the bell subscribe you'll get the
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts am
fm radio subscribe to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you